por favor dime qué arrepentiste el
crimen que cometiste
si admito mi culpabilidad entiendo que
no podrás perdonarme pero te pido perdón
es el segundo día de un juicio de gran
importancia simbólica para ucrania el
primero por crímenes de guerra desde la
invasión rusa
el acusado badín si si marín pidió
perdón a la viuda de oleksandr se lee
pop de 62 años en el cuarto día de la
invasión rusa así si marín le disparó en
la cabeza pese a ser un civil desarmado
y a
tenía un disparo en la cabeza corría
hacia él y se veía su cerebro bueno el
cráneo estaba perforado
el hecho ocurrió en la localidad de
chupan kit acá en el noreste ucraniano
algo que el acusado admitió durante el
primer día del juicio según sisi marín
vieron al hombre hablar por teléfono y
un oficial le obligó a disparar porque
podría dar la alerta al ejército
ucraniano él ordenó disparar yo no
disparé y entonces otro oficial que
estaba al lado del conductor se dio la
vuelta y comenzó a ordenar me en tono
amenazante que disparará o que de lo
contrario no alcanzaríamos a nuestras
tropas y no podríamos pedir refuerzos y
que estábamos en peligro con tan sólo 21
años y si marín era sargento y
comandante de un tanque ahora tras
admitir su culpabilidad podría
enfrentarse a cadena perpetua el soldado
dice aceptar la pena la viuda así lo
pide si bien afirma que aceptaría un
intercambio por prisioneros de aces tal